[Music]
[Music]
all the good men gone and where
where's a streetwise Hercules
[Music]
you're looking particularly beautiful
tonight
[Music]
good the identities of our serving
aliens have been exposed the country is
in a state of complete chaos and the
universe sends me you sir yes all right
buff we're going on a mission not a
honeymoon destination
south of France sir I'm the Mossad
they're just cyclists so they're French
cyclist buff and they're obstructing Her
Majesty's Secret Service she's the key
to this case I'm not sure I've ever met
a man quite like you let me clear up the
uncertainties yeah you haven't
virtual reality
it's completely immersive and some
people lose track of their actual
surroundings I think we can pretty much
guarantee that's not gonna happen tell
me the agents we've got in the field is
making some progress target acquired
this is a job for the shoe box and no
one must have a slightest clue we're
here
[Music]
till we meet again that was sooner than
I expected
[Music]